Traductor: Kevin Álvarez
Revisor: Javi Garriz
Estamos obsesionados con la felicidad.
Y no es de extrañar,
porque nos machacan hasta la saciedad
con esto de que tenemos que ser felices
para lo cual ya nos ofrecen recetas
de todo tipo y para todos los gustos.
Mindfulness, coaching,
psicoterapia positiva,
literatura de autoayuda,
fármacos del bienestar,
aplicaciones de la felicidad
para teléfonos móviles,
e incluso frases de optimismo impresas
en camisetas y en las tazas del café.
Y todas estas recetas
insisten en el mismo mensaje
y nos hacen la misma promesa.
Que ser feliz es una elección
y que cualquiera podemos serlo
porque es muy fácil,
ya que poco o nada tienen que ver
nuestras circunstancias,
pues la felicidad
es simplemente un estado mental
y una cuestión de actitud y de voluntad.
Parece que no tenemos excusa
y que hoy en día si no somos felices
es porque no queremos.
Más si cabe, cuando los denominados
científicos y expertos en bienestar
afirman haber descubierto por fin
las claves de la felicidad
y de la buena vida.
Sin embargo,
cada vez son más las investigaciones
que ponen en duda la veracidad
de estas afirmaciones
y que documentan
las consecuencias negativas
de todos estos mensajes
y de estas promesas.
Razones para dudar de este discurso
de la felicidad no faltan
porque esto de que se han descubierto
las claves para que seamos más felices
lo hemos escuchado
una y mil veces antes,
pues supuestos descubridores
de la felicidad ha habido muchos
a lo largo de la historia,
especialmente en Estados Unidos,
que es dónde debemos
situar el origen cultural
de todas estas ideas y de estos mensajes.
También, porque los usos políticos,
económicos e institucionales
que se hacen de la felicidad
no son ni mucho menos inocentes
y no siempre van
en nuestro mejor beneficio.
El ámbito de las empresas
es buen ejemplo de ello
porque a las empresas,
especialmente a las más grandes,
esto de la felicidad
les ha venido tan bien
para disfrazar ciertas formas de control
y de explotación laboral
de positividad y de crecimiento personal,
que uno diría que
de no haber existido la felicidad
serían las propias empresas
quienes la habrían inventado.
No es casual que las empresas
estén tan interesadas en la felicidad
e inviertan más de 45. 000
millones de euros al año, a nivel global.
Quizás, invirtiendo más en la suya propia
que en la de sus trabajadores.
Pues si bien hay empresas
que se preocupan de buena fe
por el bienestar de sus empleados,
sería algo ingenuo pensar
que lo que hace felices a los trabajadores
es exactamente lo mismo
que lo que hace felices a las empresas.
A pesar de la enorme inversión
que hacen las empresas en este sentido,
las últimas encuestas revelan
que más del 70 % de los trabajadores
estamos estresados
y estamos insatisfechos
con nuestros trabajos
y nuestras condiciones laborales.
También hay razones para dudar
porque el mensaje de que
quien no es feliz es porque no quiere,
esconde al menos un lado perverso.
Y es que, si la felicidad
es una elección personal,
entonces el sufrimiento también lo es,
y por tanto, quien sufre
es o bien porque quiere
o peor incluso, porque se lo merece,
porque no estaría haciendo todo lo que
se supone está en su mano para evitarlo.
¿Quiénes no hemos escuchado alguna vez
esto de que la depresión
la ansiedad, o incluso la enfermedad
nos la provocamos nosotros mismos
con nuestros pensamientos negativos
o con nuestro pesimismo?
Es un mensaje perverso, como digo,
porque una vez entramos en su lógica
en realidad no nos queda
mucho margen para la elección
sino que estamos obligados a ser felices
o al menos a aparentarlo,
aunque solo sea en defensa propia,
porque como cada vez
más estudios señalan al respecto
hoy en día, el declararse infeliz
o no lo suficientemente feliz
tiende a experimentarse, a entenderse
cada vez más como un fracaso propio,
como un signo de debilidad personal
o como el resultado de una vida emocional
mal gestionada por nuestra parte.
Y por supuesto también
hay razones para dudar
de este discurso de la felicidad
porque detrás de todas estas promesas
lo que hay, en realidad
es más ideología, que ciencia
y mucho más negocio
que simplemente buenas intenciones.
Un negocio inmenso, además,
pues hoy en día la felicidad
no sólo se vende, literalmente,
sino que se vende muy bien.
Tal y como muestran
las cifras astronómicas
que maneja esta industria
y donde tan solo la venta
de libros prácticos sobre la felicidad
genera más de 120
millones de euros al año en España
y más de quince mil millones
alrededor del mundo.
Y de este negocio, y más concretamente
de la felicidad como producto
quería hablaros
un poco más en profundidad.
Decía Zygmunt Bauman, con ironía,
que en el mundo actual todas las ideas
de la felicidad terminan en una tienda.
Lo cual es cierto.
Pero creo que la cuestión principal
es que en vez de entrar
la felicidad parece
más bien salir de las tiendas.
Es decir, que parece estar ya pensada,
ya diseñada, desde un inicio,
para circular y para ser consumida
como una mercancía.
Porque si hay algo
fuera de todo cuestionamiento
es que la felicidad ha demostrado ser
un producto redondo
y enormemente rentable.
Es muy barato de producir,
muy sencillo de suministrar
y genera enormes beneficios económicos
para todo aquel que la ofrece.
Al final va a resultar
que no eran las claves de la felicidad
lo que habían descubierto
sino las claves para vendérnosla.
Y con esas sí que parecen haber dado,
y en el clavo además.
¿Y cuáles serían estas claves?
Habría varias, pero me gustaría señalar
al menos cinco de las que considero
que son las más importantes
y que están relacionadas entre sí.
La primera de estas claves
es insistir en que esto de la felicidad
está basado en la evidencia
y que los productos que nos ofrecen
están científicamente probados.
También es importante que
todos estos productos vengan aderezados
con una buena dosis
de términos propios de la neurociencia
y cuántos más, mejor.
Digo aderezados porque
en la mayoría de los casos
el uso de estos términos
en relación con la felicidad
se hace de forma muy poco rigurosa,
muy poco precisa,
aunque nos impresionen,
que es precisamente el efecto
que pretenden conseguir con ellos.
No tanto el de informar o el de explicar
sino el de funcionar
como un argumento de autoridad,
el problema es que la ciencia
que hay detrás de la felicidad
ha demostrado ser
una ciencia bastante débil,
por lo que no está nada claro
que el recurso a la ciencia
en estos productos
vaya más allá de ser
una mera estrategia de marketing.
La segunda clave
es insistir en que la felicidad
es algo que necesita ejercitarse
y de continuo, además.
Quizás la metáfora
más recurrente al respecto
y que seguramente muchos habremos oído
es que la felicidad es un músculo,
y no un músculo cualquiera,
sino un músculo emocional que necesita
ejercitarse de forma constante.
Ya sea porque el músculo es débil
y necesite entrenamiento
o porque sea fuerte
y requiera mantenimiento,
la cuestión es que para ser felices
debemos asumir este ejercicio emocional
como una rutina o como un hábito.
La industria de la felicidad
se ofrecería aquí
como una suerte de gimnasio emocional
que pondría a nuestra disposición
toda clase de entrenadores cualificados,
de herramientas, de ejercicios
y hasta de suplementos necesarios
para que trabajemos de continuo
el músculo de nuestra felicidad,
cultivando cuestiones
como nuestro optimismo,
nuestro pensamiento positivo
o nuestras propias "fortalezas
psicológicas", como las denominan.
Siguiendo con la metáfora, se genera aquí
un curioso y problemático perfil
que en alguna ocasión he denominado
el "vigoréxico emocional",
que son estas personas, por un lado
obsesionadas con el tamaño de su yo,
de su autoestima,
con su crecimiento personal,
con su florecimiento,
y por el otro lado con una visión
distorsionada sobre sí mismas
donde nunca se ven a sí mismos
como lo suficientemente fuertes
o "musculados" en términos emocionales,
hagan lo que hagan
y se ejerciten lo que se ejerciten.
Relacionado con esto
una tercera clave es dejar entrever
que la felicidad es algo insaciable,
un camino siempre por recorrer
hacia una meta
que no llegamos nunca a alcanzar,
porque según los expertos no importa
lo satisfechos que ya estemos,
que siempre podemos ser más felices.
La felicidad, nos recuerdan a menudo,
no es la ausencia de malestar
sino la continua presencia de bienestar.
Así que ante la pregunta:
¿cuándo somos lo suficientemente felices?
La respuesta es: nunca.
Esto genera una paradoja
importante e interesante,
según la cual, la industria
de la felicidad nos promete
completa satisfacción
y realización personal,
y sin embargo, lo que hace
es producir y nutrirse de un relato
que nos dice que esta satisfacción
y realización personal
solo pueden ser parciales
o incompletas en el mejor de los casos,
pues siempre hay algo que hacer
o algo que mejorar de cara a la felicidad.
Siempre hay un pensamiento
negativo que eliminar,
un hábito más positivo que adoptar,
una fortaleza que desarrollar,
una capacidad que optimizar
o un yo más auténtico que descubrir.
Lo cual es perfecto para una industria
que se nutre de vincular
esta perpetua búsqueda de la felicidad,
esta insaciabilidad constante,
con el consumo perpetuo.
Y se genera aquí otro curioso
y problemático perfil
que algunos han denominado
el "buscador de la felicidad",
y que yo prefiero llamar
el "happycondriaco".
(Risas)
Son estas personas
que ya van a terapia,
no porque esten objetivamente mal,
sino porque querrían
estar mejor de lo que ya están.
Digamos que se sienten insatisfechas,
y hasta cierto punto vacías,
por no sentirse o por no ser
todo lo felices que creen
que podrían llegar a ser.
Una cuarta clave es insistir
en que la felicidad es algo
no ya que se aprende,
sino que se enseña.
Si bien resulta paradógico
que pueda enseñarse algo
que no se sabe muy bien qué es
y que carece de una definición
consensuada al respecto.
Es sin embargo lógico
desde el punto de vista del producto,
pues de no aprenderse,
dificilmente podría vincularse
la felicidad a la necesidad
del ejercicio emocional constante.
Y de no enseñarse,
dificilmente podría justificarse
tanto el papel del experto en bienestar,
como la existencia del producto mismo,
pues nadie compramos estos productos
por mero entretenimiento,
sino para que nos enseñen cuáles son
las guías, las recetas, los pasos,
las claves, para ser más felices.
Llama sin embargo la atención
que una meta tan supuestamente elevada
y compleja como es la felicidad,
pueda en realidad conseguirse
a través de medios tan simples
como los que acostumbran a ofrecernos.
Que si haciendo unos cuantos
ejercicios de gratitud,
que si meditando dos veces al día,
que si escribiendo unas cuantas
frases positivas en un papel,
que si leyendo este libro
o acudiendo a esta charla
que te cambia la vida.
Pero claro, en su simplicidad
reside la quinta de estas claves,
y es que los productos de la felicidad
tienen este atractivo,
de ofrecernos soluciones
simples e individuales
a problemas que son
más bien complejos y estructurales.
El mensaje de que el secreto
para lidiar con nuestros problemas
se halla en nuestro interior
es sin duda tentador,
por la sensación de control
y de empoderamiento que podría generarnos.
Sin embargo, esto tiende
a desdibujar el hecho
de que gran parte de los problemas
que estos productos prometen resolver
pongamos por caso la ansiedad,
la depresión o el estrés,
no son única o principalmente
problemas de naturaleza psicológica,
sino que son más bien problemas
de tipo estructural,
relacionados con cuestiones
como la desigualdad,
la incertidumbre económica,
la inestabilidad laboral...
A corto plazo, sin duda
algunos podríamos encontrar útil
el acudir a un curso de mindfulness,
el contratar a un coach
o el leer un libro de autoayuda
para lidiar con la ansiedad
que padecemos en el trabajo.
Pero a medio o largo plazo
no vamos a resolver con ello un problema
cuyo origen y mantenimiento
se explica frecuentemente mejor
por cuestiones de precariedad,
de competitividad o de sobrecarga laboral,
que por cuestiones
de una mala gestión emocional.
En este sentido
los productos de la felicidad
pecan de generarnos la ilusión,
en ambos sentidos de la palabra,
de que es muy fácil
cambiarnos a nosotros mismos para mejor,
que es simplemente una cuestión
de actitud y de fuerza de voluntad.
Pero por desgracia no es tan sencillo,
y creérnoslo puede generarnos
mucha frustración
además de sentido de culpabilidad,
pues al fin y al cabo puede que ni sea
tan fácil cambiarnos a nosotros mismos,
ni que podamos resolver ciertos problemas
como los que he mencionado
sin que cambien las circunstancias
que de hecho los originan,
o que los mantienen.
Pero si hay una clave principal
de todo este negocio,
esta puede resumirse, ni más ni menos,
en el enorme éxito
que ha tenido toda esta industria
en que normalicemos
la obsesión con la felicidad.
Porque aquí la cuestión no es
que seamos o que no seamos felices
tanto como que estemos constantemente
preocupados por si lo somos o no lo somos.
Que estemos constantemente ocupados
en perseguir esa felicidad prometida
bajo el convencimiento, además,
de que existen, y de que alguien
tiene las claves -científicas,
para colmo-, para encontrarla.
Lo cual, como insinuaba anteriormente
no parece ser el caso.
Quisiera enfatizar diciendo
que esta charla no es un alegato
en contra de la alegría, de las sonrisas,
de la esperanza, o a favor de la tristeza.
Tampoco es un alegato en contra
de toda forma de felicidad posible
es más bien una invitación
a cuestionar esta forma de felicidad
tan individualista, tiránica
y sobretodo consumista
que industria, empresas, científicos
y expertos en bienestar promueven,
y de la que quizás sean ellos
los más beneficiados.
Es una invitación a poner en duda
esta felicidad con la que hoy en día
parecemos estar obsesionados
y yo diría que no para bien.
Para terminar y como viene siendo habitual
en este tipo de charlas y escenarios
me gustaría finalizar la mía
con un mensaje positivo
(Risas)
Y es que como de las obsesiones,
como de las adicciones,
como de las desilusiones,
o como de los desengaños,
la buena noticia es
que de la felicidad también se sale.
(Aplausos)